yo what up this the boy Dame
representing play too much CMG hey man
check me out on bootleg cab podcast yeah
it's the bootleg cab show special guests
in here
from the bay
my guy I finally made it Dane the boy
Dame is here what up man I made it
people who don't know uh what do you do
because I feel like you DJ you a r and
you're putting out records what do you
got a record label yeah man my
employment title is I'm the I'm the head
a r over at CMG with Gotti right
um
for my own stuff man I got my own label
play too much and I'm an artist over at
Def Jam so
how did you start off in the bank
because you obviously have roots in the
bay and from what I understand the Yo
Gotti [ __ ] popped off because you put
them on the pillow [ __ ] right yeah yeah
that was my first a r record
um man I started off as an intern like
with Chewie Gomez shout out to Chewie
the legend that's my Legend like my my
big homie Chewie and then from being at
the station running around with Vine in
my emotion
um then they taught they forced me out
of DJ you know what I'm saying I used to
just kind of play around on people stuff
after the shows my emotion was like bro
don't disrespect our culture like that
like yeah go practice how to blend and
match the BPM and stuff like that so
just getting into that and I started
picking out local records that end up
becoming something in the bay so I guess
they start believing in my musical
Talent which records uh Rod I can't
stand you the r b record
um and I was picking a bunch of B-side
records like Plies I'm really from the
hood uh just that type of stuff to where
Vining them was like he kind of know
what he talking about they ain't give me
the food you know what I'm saying and uh
I realize radio man them dudes it's like
it's only four spots you know four time
spots yeah so I knew and they was making
a lot of money I knew them dudes wasn't
about to quit or retire no time soon so
I had to make a transition and uh
I was also like the little go get it
dude at the station like go get some
coffee no no no no other girl get like
Street go get it like we need some
[ __ ] we need some weed artists yeah
we needed something to hold us down that
type of stuff so I was building that
relationship with a bunch of the artists
and um Gotti was one of the artists that
I went to build the relationship with
right
um I don't know he took a like in B
memes his cousin took a liking it to me
they invited me to the studio radio was
already like dying out for me right and
uh [ __ ] I was in Oakland they hit me up
send me the address but the uh the
studios in Burbank you know everybody
think California is close it's crazy
yeah yeah so I'm like [ __ ] it I just got
in the car and drove out here
then I went to the studio I had to go
walk through a bunch of Memphis [ __ ]
and you know they like play some beats
and that's when the mustard was cracking
right
um I'm Different was that all right
everybody wanted one of them yeah yeah
and uh
so I started playing a bunch of bees but
bro was like he kind of was like he
wasn't feeling them and he's like man
you got one more record and man I caught
pilo I'm like please send me a Beat and
I end up being act right
um
we it's a little joke though I think he
was kind of dissing this though still
because he said I'm going going back to
the bay that's a piece of Mac Dre I
think he was sending me back to the Bay
like you catching else like send us back
to the bank but he said it in the whole
room was like you know what I'm saying
like a and R's in there I even know
where the a r was back then
um they all went crazy for it so what is
that
like you said you didn't know what a r
was a lot of people don't know what an a
r was the evil way to lie and say you're
in the industry that sounds about right
but what exactly does an anr do like
what is like what is the title entail
yeah in 2022 it was staying for artists
and repertoire and uh it's different
anrs though you got your lifestyle a RS
what's that even mean those are people
gonna make sure you had all the right
parties and get them pictures they're
gonna make you look like a star sounds
like a publicist to me it could be okay
you know that's an A and R okay you got
your creatives who like
in the studio picking to be helping you
with the song right getting the feature
for you
um that's what I'm more on the creative
AMR and then you got your admin they're
just making sure you following that
budget know how to close out your album
and all that stuff so so like if you
need to get like a side agreement with
an artist that hopped on some [ __ ] or
yeah yeah they making sure the producer
agreement is done with credits and the
lyrics gotcha yeah yeah so it's a few
different ones but so there's a few
different those are the ones who
actually get salaries yeah man the ones
where people be hustling you know yeah
they're full of [ __ ] yeah yeah yeah it's
the easiest job to lie about though in
the industry you know I'm an R yeah what
the homies you just the Entourage you I
think that some perception of what an
anr is
that may be inaccurate is
a liaison to get art assigned to a major
label like if you're in a r somewhere
you got the power to sign somebody I
mean if you had a real job you would do
okay if you get if you had a real like
you know I was at Motown before
um I'm a CMG man so like I signed
artists
um I guess it's how much power you got
at the label but that's your job if you
ever help us find or sign someone to CMG
he had to do the Mozzy deal oh shout out
to Mozzy yeah yeah my boy so free Mozzy
yeah by the way shout out to Dave and
his team because his Instagram it's like
he never wins I just saw he did a
[ __ ] promo plug for the Pax company I
said oh I see yeah they was working but
you know I did Mozzy I brought a few
people to CMG that just didn't work out
but they still are people any other West
Coast folks uh brought Kamaya early
really yeah yeah yeah
pre-400 yeah pre 400 this was I was
probably like one of the people early
people at the crib for the for the how
does it feel you know what I'm saying
like we broke still super slept on she's
incredible yeah you know she one of the
dope is uh I brought Dej Loaf early wow
I'm talking about 1200 followers man
somehow she's like one of the most
influential female rappers now when you
hear all these when you hear all these
new girls I'm like damn this sound like
a fake ass day yeah loaf is my heart
though I talk to loaf all the time so
yeah she's dope she should be back at it
soon on uh who else we brought over
there you know me and Gotti got this
thing when people get hot we check our
DMS to see if they hit us got you and
majority of the times like they had
reached out they reached out we might
have just missed it or just like we had
the combo but it didn't turn into
nothing right right right well God is
also doing these deals where he's just
like [ __ ] on Instagram handing
someone like a million dollars
it got in different times
Christ yeah yeah and I got him I want to
know is all that cash recupable
that's a Yo Gotti question yeah you
gotta answer that but it's like I just
handed you three hundred thousand
dollars in cash not not a wire not a
check
does this go over is this a part of our
balance but you know if bro believed in
you he that all that stuff handled later
right like half the time Gotti doing
stuff with people before they even
signed to him yeah yeah it's not I mean
I know like the last time I was in the
studio with him he just had like a
SoundCloud playlist he was just new [ __ ]
he was [ __ ] like undiscovered people
yeah nah he owned it man our a and our
team is it ain't big but it's it's we we
solidified like it's me CMG Breezy
um cmgb and then uh even like little
Bella over at Interscope like
our little sis she be on her [ __ ] too
uh uh for you like uh obviously being a
West Coast guy coming into such a dope
position priming a position with us I
guess the southern label if you would
call it
um how important you think that is
because I do feel like at times
really especially the bay the Bay's like
his own world yeah and sometimes it's
hard to be an artist from the bay and
penetrate the rest of the country yeah
people will take the bass sound and make
it not make it national you know make it
big you know uh but in terms of like
just artists in the Bay Area that you
know obviously
this it feels like sometimes the ceiling
is is not as high as if someone's from
Memphis or someone's from Atlanta you
mean yeah but now that that you have
very representation and one of the
hardest you know
what cruise in the game I mean for the
bay you know what I'm saying like
sometimes it's just the artist that we
probably will Champion as not on because
we got National artists yeah you got
kehlani G-Eazy okay yeah you know what
I'm saying people making it
um I just think it's the ones we
Champion not making it because we've
seen them like grow you know what I'm
saying I think like with your 24K like
it might look like he just popped out
but like I hosted the talent show with
him I didn't even pick him in the talent
show they told me wow you know what I'm
saying I wish I did because I probably
would have been locked in with her but
you know it's it's different artists who
like
we just seen them work a lot you know
what I'm saying like Simba we sing he
was probably like our first bit when we
did the Bay Area freshman lose I think
he was on that list you know what I'm
saying yeah Sim has been active for a
very long time yeah so I think it's just
you know
sometimes it's not the ones that we all
pick that actually get the shot but um
you know people who work hard like Simba
like they still get they shot and they
got the support from the crib that's
what I said I said like
a lot of times people use that excuse
like lack of support from where they're
from as I can excuse why they're not
bigger
as opposed to just looking in the mirror
and saying I gotta get to work I got to
work harder yeah that's the biggest it's
always a reason like I don't got no like
issues outside at the crib right like on
some outside [ __ ] Street [ __ ] my only
issues come from my heart is who that
old who think like it's my fault it's
your fault like yo why ain't you sign me
bro right right that shit's crazy that's
the only thing I do yeah yeah what
inspired you to start dropping records
um
I kind of wanted I wanted my credit for
some stuff that I was doing and uh you
know when you're behind the scenes like
ain't too many people reading credits on
albums on Spotify right
um and like when you like on some NR
[ __ ] like only like industry people may
know like you might look like you're not
doing [ __ ] to the world right so like I
figured like man if I started doing some
records then maybe people start being
like man that's bro who did this or
that's who you know what I'm saying I
use it as my resume technically
um and then when I looked up I had like
12 13 records with some of the hottest
people so Gotti encouraged me like right
she started putting out some records
yeah why not yeah yeah so you were just
put because you had put together another
record uh two or three years ago that
was like G was on it who else was like
oh yeah uh days loaf got in G-Eazy yeah
that was when I was at Motown okay okay
yeah yeah yeah yeah so this is like your
second go round with this yeah this is
my second deal what happened how did you
get uh like obviously shout out to Def
Jam Def Jam doesn't have the craziest
like huge roster it seems like it's a
very small roster
you know they got Big Sean like a YG I'm
forgetting a bunches
but in terms of like uh you linking up
with them what was uh what was their
like like how was that process uh so I
was fresh out of my deal with Motown
right and um
man I kind of was trying to figure out
like we was ready to go at Motown like
the songs was ready to go the features
like and then it just got shut down so I
just went back to a r heavy with Gotti
and um
one of my boys Helene a r over at devjam
we probably talk every day anyway and he
was like bro you got too many records
like I'm over here at Def Jam like they
need something yeah you represent the
street like you your music is on some
Street [ __ ] like devjam is still a
street label so he was like let's see if
we could do something uh tunji and all
in was heading over there so it worked
out he panned out we got to stop the
interview real quick to tell you about
our folks at my bookie ladies and
gentlemen [ __ ] NFL season is
approaching it's my favorite time of the
year God damn it it's good times and the
Rams versus the bills is happening
kicking off the whole regular season and
there's no way to get ready for that
regular season like getting ready for
that winning season all right I'm
talking about putting some [ __ ]
money in your pocket you could be a
veteran better like me or you could be a
first time better and you just want to
get a little taste of the action my
bookie has got you because right now
they got that double deposit bonus if
you sign up at mybookie.ag right now go
to my bookie it's quick and easy let's
say you put 200 150 bucks in you get 500
to gamble with that's right it's a
double deposit bonus but you have to use
the promo code
bootleg
b-o-o-t-l-e-g it's also in the
description of this video you can just
click the link and you're in there so go
to mybookie.com use that double deposit
bonus by using the promo code bootleg
you gotta register today use it and
let's get this NFL season [ __ ]
cracking I'm talking listen I don't even
know the line of the Rams Bills game
it's about a week out on some change
away depending on what the [ __ ] you're
watching this but
Bill's money line what are we doing all
right my bookie sign up use that promo
code bootleg right now and get that
double deposit bonus if you put in a
thousand dollars you get two thousand
dollars to gamble with you put a hundred
you get 200. it's that [ __ ] easy my
bookie go run it up let's get back to
the interview let me ask you this when
you go to Motown and it doesn't pan out
and you have all these records can you
take them with you yeah because they
ain't pay for them okay
I can't do nothing like you know what
I'm saying like I never had to turn them
in because we never got there it's crazy
because Motown I feel like mishandled
like I swear Vezzo so crazy and now he's
with well he's way back he's outside
invisible that was my first artist to
Motown yeah oh really yeah yeah but
that's dope to see I don't know what his
QC deal is like but qc's over there yeah
yeah in the same building yeah so it's
gonna be funny that like now you're
working with the same people but I think
they got to run it back again yeah he
did what he again Vezzo I was like some
people I feel like a major label
holds him back yeah so like with this
when I first went to Motown I was like
okay y'all Detroit label I mean it's
still Motown from Detroit I'm like y'all
ain't well you ain't got no rappers you
know being Oakland in Detroit like I
know they cracking yeah Detroit's huge
in the back and um they kind of wasn't
familiar I'm like Vezzo was just coming
home which is like the best promo you
could ever have Bros coming home from
jail unfortunately but
um I actually Ethiopia was like go get
them you know what I'm saying I'm like
yo they about to go up this would be for
Doug you know what I'm saying I think
right at that moment it's like 20 18 19
18. yeah yep so he came home from jail
signed him out the halfway house
um it was an experience for both of them
my first label his first time being on
the major so I think we were just still
trying to figure it all out together and
um you know a little couple restraints
but
when he went off on his own he wouldn't
got cracking him and he went up yeah
yeah they I think it's dope though when
he when he called me about it and he
asked me my opinion I said well you know
the Personnel yeah like man they already
know to manage it yeah you already kind
of know the deal over there so yeah so
now you got the Insight on how you
should move but uh now Ethiopia support
our artist though so cute man got QC uh
co-signer yeah no he's hard
him and Kodak [ __ ] crazy too super crazy
100 uh rich off pints three out now go
run that [ __ ] shout out to my boyfriend
um when it comes to
putting out records
everybody's always very like you know
when we think of a guy like DJ Khaled
yeah like does he have to pay for the
features do you have to pay an artist to
be on a record or is it more of like I
[ __ ] with you here's the verse um if I
don't know him or if they're not aware
of my stuff of course like that's just
business but like my project is damn
near CMG Album Time like part two really
yeah like I'm still CMG like you know
what I'm saying so you got everybody on
there the whole roster on there
um bad glorilla
estg got it got it I think Gotti on
there twice Doug on there twice yeah the
whole team on there so will they have
the CMG logo on the back next to the Def
Jam logo or is it just Def Jam play too
much I'm always conclude CMG like got
the executive producing my house so I
mean if he wanted the logo on there I'm
saying CMG on half the songs anyway so
that's I mean [ __ ] why not yeah but
features don't lie you you gotta like my
first record was with Ross and G right
um I got Ross off a DM like I just sent
him a DM he did the verse so I took care
of him I think they still giving me like
a crazy discount just because of my
affiliation with CMG though so you had
to pay but it wasn't like what everyone
else has to pay yeah I ain't paying what
the what they said in the songs nah yeah
I feel like when an artist quotes what
they are charging somebody that is like
if they don't know who the [ __ ] you are
right right and you somehow got the
verse and they know you got a bag yeah
like if a K-pop by the way shout out my
guy Gucci Mane Gucci got a [ __ ] crazy
bag off a K-Pop group a few years ago
shout out Spencer but like if it's some
[ __ ] like that yeah where it's like oh
no yeah let's go hard let's go high but
for the most part it's like it was
respectable enough to me to still shake
their hand and have convo and you know
what I'm saying lock in with them but I
only had to pay like
maybe three artists and I got 17 songs
oh that's great yeah you know I worked
in my favor the artist you don't pay you
you cut them in a little more on this on
the pub side let's just do swaps because
you know I still produce an a r so you
know but like CMG is family we don't
keep pointing we don't keep tabs on
favors and stuff like that so pretty
much was good and then the rest of them
is a artist from the crib from the back
so who often the base on your project
um so I got my artist on there uh that
uh not about to say days love uh little
pears it's a female rapper
um she don't like two songs crazy songs
like she on The Cypher song with Simba
40 and Chip was oh [ __ ] um I think she
could out rap anybody so she dope um she
got sung on there with Jacquees
project Papa who I'm my new single with
a guardian Jeezy
um he on there and then I got an R B
singer Nick K she got a song with 42
though so you're very uh I mean it's
dope that you're committed to making
sure
the representation yeah the boy on there
he's hard now he might I tell him he
like ice cube when NWA broke up just
going crazy yeah just keep going you
know what I'm saying uh who else on it
from the crib it's a few people but not
a crib on there and I just mixed it in
with like some of the Legends like
Khaled and drama on there
um because you know clearly right of
course they the foundation of what I'm
of course really is DJ Clue what clue
drama is not the guy and and and Khaled
like the Jay-Z of this music I remember
the first [ __ ] dropping albums
was clue and flex
Flex had this yeah I was like a young I
was like a kid kid Flex has some crazy
[ __ ] clue had the professional yeah yeah
crazy [ __ ] like clue record is the Jay-Z
and Meyer one technically right yeah
yeah so I think that was on the
professional too yeah I knew who they
was but I'm saying like no no I mean
listen Khalid and drama are like I
always say drama is a great I mean the
most important greatest hip-hop DJ ever
I'm on time I'm not talking about
scratching I'm talking about yeah what
he means to the culture what he's
contributed I mean this guy just hosted
best rap album of the year that won a
Grammy Tyler yeah you know what I'm
saying he big homie too like whenever I
need them he'll make sure to like right
whatever I need I got you whatever you
need are you like talking [ __ ] on the
songs nah that's probably for the better
I kind of learned off them too though
right like I remember being at the radio
and like they used to sing records
without them on it yeah so DJs you know
DJ we ain't yeah there would be the no
DJ version of mixtape ain't gonna
promote just yeah another DJ like that
so
um I kind of learned this from John
Little John I do all my hooks though
okay so you're doing your hooks yeah so
the DJs you technically still got to
play the record like right without me
saying it's the war that ain't all that
[ __ ] yeah I might talk some [ __ ] about
getting some money but I ain't know the
worst is when you're in a club and
someone plays a song that's the mixtape
version and there's like some other
people attacks drops all over it and I'm
like [ __ ] man yo that's why I really
[ __ ] with drama and Canon like I
remember being an intern I think I might
be the first one to ask him you know I
got Autumn like I got some of them Lil
Wayne Dedication tapes without them
talking on it nice yeah like Canon used
to like Canon gave me like you know yeah
I remember the blogs used to drop the
normal version and then like three days
later the no DJ version and it'd be like
I got I got a couple of drama records
without drama from the mixtape here nice
yeah who uh I saw you and uh King Vaughn
had a discussion about the best Bay Area
rappers ever
yeah yeah me and Bobby had it who's your
top five
um
E40 number one
of course 40 number one to me I think he
the winner of all winners period
um definitely Too Short yeah
um
number three I'm gonna go with the Jacka
okay that was my big bro
um number four I'm gonna go with Fab
okay Fab like
Fab is really the mayor of Oakland or
the Bay Area like he could go anywhere
people respect him and he got some
records that's classics
uh number five
keep this name cake yeah I'm gonna go
key I respect it yeah no Mac Dre
man I'm gonna drink that people Vallejo
I love Vallejo they get on my ass about
this all the time I always say to my
friends who are from the bay
I think Mac Dre is overrated I'm never
gonna say that I say it shout out to
kilo no matter my people all I said is
no no no from somebody who did not live
in the bay and and the music was not
important to me like it is to everybody
else obviously feeling myself and
there's records that are I get it but in
terms of like
the way y'all hold Mac Dre up there no
we hold him up there being somebody
who's not from there yeah I'm just like
all right so so the thing with Dre is
he had his core fans right which was
like everyday people right
it necessarily wasn't in like the
blackest times if I could say that like
it was more like Latinos and white
people
he always had the crazy [ __ ] artwork
and yeah yeah like those was like
popping thieves and [ __ ] like that was
that [ __ ] you know black people kind of
this iffy on drugs at first so
the side shows and all that let's keep
this neat nobody out did keep for side
shows and the Jack of hey girl and all
them records so Drake kind of like
caught the win unfortunately right
before he died and when he died
so Dre never even got to perform filling
myself in all those records he never got
to fully feel
what what he means to the bathe like
today because like now nowadays no yeah
like he didn't like I you know I feel
like um in the same way that Pock never
probably got to really feel what he
meant until you know once he passed I
think people yeah like when people did
they bake Chris Brown and then Drake
they probably would have been bringing
Dre out right but like he didn't get to
see like his biggest songs he wasn't
here for stress told me like he passed
away like a month before the album
dropped or after the album dropped so a
lot of that stuff is like
legendary [ __ ] that he never even got he
never even got to see the results of it
yeah he never got to perform at like a
Summer Jam or you know what I'm saying
like he didn't get the shutdown on an
arena right right right right right
everything was more trivial but nah
Drake is deaf like you know he
definitely dope but I'm talking about
when I grew up in Oakland like these was
the five people pick hyphy era before I
before it was even a hyphy when it was
just yo keep the sneak hyphy did you
think because if you think of like um my
ghetto report card being like the
biggest hyphy album
but at the time wasn't 40 not really
considered a hyphy artist
yeah 40 like the winner the Mages lived
through all of our moments yeah 40 is
like uh Timeless in terms of like
every time he puts an album out it's
[ __ ] fire and it doesn't matter how
what era we're in he adjusts he gets the
right features it's crazy but in terms
of like my ghetto report card like
because I feel like the hyphy movement
was something that was like
very uh
Grassroots
I guess to really fully appreciated you
had to live there
might get a report card was like
it took the [ __ ] to a whole nother level
it was the Perfection of it it was crazy
because it took it it took it to like
such a crazy level that like you know a
[ __ ] tell me when to go as a record you
could play
[ __ ] in Brooklyn you know whatever
you know what I'm saying you know I
think 40 was just like he the winner of
all time so he was able to dabble he
could do whatever he wants and be and
make it the the best quality of it like
if it could have been and he had little
John on that like yeah what are you such
the winner that he can polish it right
you know like Dilo NoHo is unmixed it
sounds like it a classic but yes but
like if 40 had it would have been mixed
little job it would have been even major
dilo's another one of those guys from
the Bay who is a big deal but you know
is is somebody who's maybe their
potential wasn't seen nationally
if that makes sense yeah but you never
should go on the stage after if you're
performing no he's crazy he did my
birthday party one year in Phoenix and
it was [ __ ] crazy it's hard to
perform at the Delo in the bay yeah like
he got probably like four certified
records that's like the bay in General's
got songs that like didn't work anywhere
else for like artists not from the bay
yeah that are [ __ ] huge there we're
the B-side Capital it's crazy yeah
they'll take pride in it though like
what's the Mike Jones song flossing
flossing Jesus Christ is Mike Jones
flossing it's uh Young Dro high five uh
uh Birdman out the ghetto
like this [ __ ] like when you when you
play they go like why are you playing
this [ __ ] but out there
yeah like then they're like oh [ __ ] man
you probably should have did this [ __ ]
you know what I'm saying so we like to
be B-side Capital though like why do you
think that is
but I think we all amrs at some point
you know what I'm saying like because
well I think it for me it originated
like
before the hyphy movement like the
original side shows it almost used to be
like what's the coolest song you can
play that nobody knows like let me find
something on the album yeah like you
would have uh we know the single is
going to get played but let me find this
other joint it'll be like a [ __ ] coming
down the street in a van 4 15 slapping
The Gap Band Outstanding in the middle
of a bunch of gangsters right or Goapele
Closer like that [ __ ] like it was some
real killer slapping closer saving me
heart out you know what I'm saying or so
it used to just be like a one-up like
what song can I slap that nobody else no
one else is slapping yeah that makes
sense I think that personifies a pretty
yeah yeah so we big on that beat the
b-sides appreciate y'all watching but
listen our partners at Blue chew they
got you handled fellas and Etc whatever
you are thank God if you got a dick
Bluetooth is for you because they will
make sure your dick performs at all time
levels I mean like LeBron his first
three seasons with the heat type levels
I mean your wife will thank you for for
it everybody will thank you for it [ __ ]
even if you just take a blue chew and
jerk your dick it's a it's a stronger
jerk I swear to God stronger [ __ ] jerk
for sure you're gonna be beating your
dick like a stole something so what you
got to do is go to bluetooth.com right
now use the promo code bootleg right now
and you're gonna get your first month
free and this is the great thing about
Bluetooth the same active ingredients as
Viagra and scialis
but uh you don't got to go to the
doctor's office yeah who wants to go
hang out at the doctor's office and be
like hey Doc you got some [ __ ] pills for
me nobody wants to do that no you sign
up at Blue use the promo code bootleg
and you're getting your first month
delivered to your door in discrete
packaging I'm telling you you're gonna
thank me later all right if you've
gotten Bluetooth already just DM me tell
me just just DM me no photos just tell
me how you know let me just tell you
it's [ __ ] amazing our producer
Cyrus's daddy 70 took the blue chew he's
[ __ ] just beating down all the senior
citizen [ __ ] available in Arizona right
now so go to bluetooth.com use that
promo code bootleg or just hit the link
in the description of this video let's
get back to the interview uh this was
there ever on this project when you put
artists together on a record do you have
to like let them know this guy's gonna
be on the song Too to make sure there's
no like
issues yeah uh I mean I'm pretty aware
of most people that I'm cool with issues
but there's also some weird behind the
scenes [ __ ] yeah yeah sometimes that we
don't know about about [ __ ]
I mean I was pretty good though I think
they kind of respect my position just
anyway right but um now nobody Only
Knows songs that don't really rock I got
like an old record with all the females
on it right they all get along it was
cool with it it's kind of yes it's tough
to see most of the female rappers are
embracing each other yeah yeah they
going crazy it's crazy glory is fun I
just had her in here and we
it was [ __ ] hilarious glow going
crazy I don't even know we could say
like glow about the light
lock in with glow right now that's all I
tell people if you could get the verse
get the verses get the verse now yeah
and try to figure it out later because
it's some [ __ ] about to go to Anna where
it's going to be like the remix
besides the remix
like some big dog low [ __ ] some Nicki
Minaj [ __ ] like a big dog loves some uh
I don't know I just know it's big dog
[ __ ] okay yeah the emails is real
private okay okay but I know like people
should lock in with glow right now if
they can
who's the funnest person to hang out
with in CMG I know it's going to be
black youngsta so just tell me why it's
black youngster I don't even want to
answer the question obviously black
youngsta is the funnest guy to hang out
with tell me your black youngster story
uh maybe like next week was on tour
together we did the Canada run when he
first came to CMG he's a great guy
hilarious guy black youngsta is just
he's excited about life yeah so
everything to him is fun you know what
I'm saying he needs a podcast he
definitely should he'd be [ __ ] I'm
trying to but you know what who like
really funny and he don't Gotti is funny
as [ __ ] yeah he just like you know he
like a private person though so but like
God you know how to like do impressions
of other people though really like if he
ever telling you a story about an artist
he literally knows how to talk just like
him really man this [ __ ] is like I only
know how to talk just like him when I
say murder everybody
and milk some like milk and music is
like wow but not like because Gotti got
a bunch of rap stories like yo he's been
around me TBT days like yeah and then
leaving tvt he had to pretty much just
like hit reset yeah like the Cash Money
area he was in yeah you know what I'm
saying like the the TI's the G's like he
was around me he was around so much [ __ ]
like Dr Dre and made up like dude got
some stories that's like that's crazy
like I got you the Nate Dogg story I
gotta hear that one he got like a all
right the Nate dog story consistent made
dog Dr Dre in the game okay yeah I got
to hear that story next time I interview
him yeah he could that [ __ ] is amazing
that [ __ ] could be like a remembering uh
who was a Killer Mike did the animated
yeah it could be a little cartoon
that [ __ ] is crazy
were you there when he lost all that
money gambling with the Jay-Z and
everybody yeah I was in the crap yeah I
was like I mean we gamble we blackjacked
yeah but that [ __ ] hurt my heart yeah we
all got like cause I know he's got it
but oh I don't know who got it but we
like real blackjack please no I get it I
get it but I'm just saying that one
specific I don't know if it was a hand
or was it a bro was it I think he was no
it was Blackjack and I think he was at
like 16 in the dealership like 13.
so he didn't hit he hit oh he did hit
and that's what we all was like like we
played blackjack him cmgv me like this
[ __ ] is like strategy like we all got
our own strategy so for I think me and
cmgb was there we were kind of looking
at you like what the [ __ ] did he just
hit on the 16 for
I would say for my boy though I would
have probably I was sick I saw that [ __ ]
I said and he just was like
he did because he ain't gonna ever show
you like oh I'd be [ __ ] I [ __ ] but
he got to the table though it was one of
the things like what the [ __ ] was you
doing right he was like bro I don't know
I think it was that's usually how it
goes when you're in Vegas and you are
down a bunch of you're just like [ __ ]
yeah I didn't see him like wipe out
Vegas though too oh I'm sure yeah I
didn't see him anybody who's willing to
gamble that much on one hand has also
won no I didn't seem like Sakina like
when the Men in Black come stand behind
you like it's it's too up like um yeah I
didn't see a guy like the Palms we own
that we own the Palms yeah I want no
part of that I've gambled so much money
away especially on Sports oh yeah I
don't do Sports again sports betting is
yeah it's wild uh you're obviously a
Warriors fan unfortunately of course
um yeah how you feeling about the
Warriors he said unfortunately okay good
man we stayed down we had a rough two
years but we stayed down yeah you know
what I'll say this
I met Draymond Green the other night oh
yeah very nice guy yeah
and I hate him but I don't hate him you
hate him as a fan yeah I don't hate him
as a dude but you know from a Fan's
perspective he's our antagonists God
damn he's like Patrick Beverly but for
the Warriors but just not as dirty and
we win and you guys win yeah yeah boy
like it was crazy my little homie Juan
played for us last year he's from oh
he's in the Lakers now he on the Lakers
now so it was dope to see one get a ring
you know Steph always been down like
Steph probably like the most Untouchable
figure him and clay
yeah like clay be with Jim in them and
all black YC clay riding his bike
everywhere like with Clay be like
I don't know why they even have it but
I've seen him in the nightclub in
Scottsdale before randomly and I'm just
like why is what I would know like
nobody knew he was coming he was just
ends up in a section clay good I seen
the video like a couple years ago Steph
was in West Oakland getting gas
not touched nice like a [ __ ] are like
oh Stephy C and he's like what's up I
was like they'll let you know when you
but but you're not wearing the Under
Armor sneakers
if I did an event if I did a step yeah I
mean obviously they gotta pay they gotta
pay you to wear them it's not going my
FIT though no yeah for like as great of
a player he is top three worst
basketball shoe of all no hell no
because you got to go there like some of
these new Shacks
Shacks was trash when he left nah but
Reebok was solid yeah I said everybody
you know what I don't even think he had
an official shoe after he left he just
had a brand brand so we'll exclude Shaq
because remember when Ryan artez did
that were terrible horrible
uh well those are the Spree Wheels
though right well there was the Speedos
with the rim in them
um there's been some trash we ain't
giving stuff to top trash because Steph
put colors on this [ __ ] so
you know a lot of colors in the
basketball look cool now top five worse
than nah man there you go Steph I'm
rocking with you what's what's worse uh
uh Kawhi Leonard's New Balance
or Steph's under oh yeah
when New Balances fly yeah I got a bunch
of 550s I got some new guys on my feet
right now I'm embracing and man they
sent me some free shoes and they were
sitting in my closet for like three
years and I was going to Rolling loud
like a couple weeks ago so I was like
you know what let me wear these [ __ ]
things because I'm gonna be on my feet
comfortable I threw them [ __ ] on I
said I like this I'm 35. I might have to
start [ __ ] up these great boys yeah I
got I got about 10 550s that [ __ ]
great shoe comfortable shoes my boy over
there he make sure we good I need his
number I'll get you off I'm on the dad
shoe the dad shoe wave now man yeah now
rock with that I just buy Jordans in
like every pair of Jordans that comes
out that I like I buy but then they I
don't wear them yeah I keep up here Jay
I end up just wearing like the same like
three pairs of shoes and then I just
have [ __ ] stacks of Jordans that just
don't get worn I've been using Jordans
for my studio fix though man so what's
your going to the club shoe
man I'm uh you can never go wrong with
Air Force Ones they one-time wears
though but uh one time yeah one time and
then they come house shoes
um I'm on a three-day run with the ones
I got today because we had to do a video
shoot I'm like I'm not messing up no
[ __ ] we're in uh there's Benny The
Butcher show in uh
you know it's a Griselda show at The
Shrine a couple months ago
and Benny took off Air Force Ones in the
parking lot just left them there so I
grabbed them [ __ ] and gave them to my
son they're the same size Brand New Pair
he could at least sign them no no no no
no no no no he'd already like pulled off
and I was like cool everyone's gone I
can grab those and not look crazy let me
grab these [ __ ] one one Air Force
maybe some house shoes after though
getting to my son he got a brand new
pair of horses my shout out to I got
about
I got a second room full Air Force Ones
that's too much I mean when you be with
you know they they don't even feel the
same
you walk taller when they're a fresh
pair no you're right so wait wait so you
have a room just for forces no like my
second room is really all my shoes but
half of the room is all white Air Force
Ones
why don't you just donate them I do
donate some of them because um like my
name my mom neighbor like he like
restores them so he took a few pair
before
like I said they become house shoes we
gotta stop the interview tell you about
our partners at Odd Socks well first of
all let's check out the brand new collab
look at these the bootleg capsock you
see my pink ass face on those [ __ ]
socks nobody wants to buy those we're
going to figure out a way to give them
away though uh but look Odd Socks the
most comfortable socks in the world
um and the best thing about Odd Socks is
they're our family man I've been walking
with these guys for about 10 years now
and I will not wear anything else on my
feet like I swear to God I'm about to
take my shoe off I'm about to take the
look what is this
smells great too that's an odd sock
right there that's an odd sock basic you
know what I'm saying we [ __ ] with Odd
Socks you should too they got the crazy
licenses we're talking about Nickelodeon
shout out to Patrick [ __ ]
Cheez-Its Baywatch
how about macaroni underwear look at
these boys right here let's just crack
these [ __ ] open real quick what
do we got in here
come on man
yeah a little Pop-Tart underwear yeah I
mean yeah these are the Odd Socks Basics
all right so if you go to the website
right now order you some underwear order
you some socks use the promo code
bootleg Kev that's one word all together
bootleg Kev and you will save 20 off at
checkout go to oddsoxofficial.com one
more time that's oddsocksofficial.com
promo code bootleg Kev and you will save
20 off your order of course we're
presented by Odd Socks and we are proud
to say so all right let's get back to
the interview
uh when are you uh dropping uh your
project your full album uh before the
year I think we trying to come November
maybe even October
I'm waiting for one feature though
poo
well we trying to wait for like Chris
but I know you're on tour yeah like the
big big dogs is not as easy to get of
course like you got to go through like
cousins managers right managers why
really it's like getting that like it's
so hard because it's like
when people go to the studio that's that
big it's really they're going for a
reason yeah and it's like how do you get
your record to be in the mix of like I
gotta do it right now while they're
there it's almost like you have to go
and pull up
but even then they still get you like I
got you right but yeah it's it's tough
but like those people like somebody like
a Chris Brown
like dude is a big dog right right so
like
I'm sure you got a a waiting list of 100
[ __ ] waiting to get the crew oh 100
and he's like the hook God so it's like
yo everybody went I bet you everyone
wants Chris Brown yeah so you almost
trying to find like what's the fastest
route to him right and I think I took it
for granted because CMG being so popping
like I literally could just call back
and say I need a verse and it's like all
right cool two days you got your verse
right or like if you came up in Cali we
all came together like Ty Dollar yeah
the YG's and all them but like the
people you don't know
it's tougher yeah I mean that's kind of
the whole reason to be the guy you are
yeah yeah yeah use your relationship guy
right right so it's kind of tough all
them early college records have the same
[ __ ] on them same for people it
was like Plies T-Pain [ __ ] little
Wayne Ross Trick Daddy I'd like to bring
back the Plies on Khalid records [ __ ]
you know uh Trend or just Plies in
general Plies mean more fly it really
hurt my feelings I'm gonna sell you this
though I had Plies on my record like and
he killed it like killed the record okay
we just wasn't able to get it business
finished really it wasn't Plies faulty
but
is he still in Atlantic I don't know but
I got I got it right with somebody you
know I'm gonna talk to play directly
about damn but it was like when like it
was applies verse to where like
everybody heard it and was like
yeah Plies is fire man he don't really
feel like he's I lived in Tampa for a
few years and I really got to see like
some of them B-side records that like go
crazy in Florida like that [ __ ] or like
there's so many records one more time
you got so much [ __ ] yeah shout out to
Plies all right so your album's coming
uh before the end of the year new single
out with Ross no my new singles wait
well yeah get the raw single out there
new single that just dropped Jeezy yep
he'll go crazy with Jeezy uh Gotti and
then my new artist project Papa out of
Oakland out of Oakland where it is
turned the shout out to Oakland shout
out to the Bay you gotta come out there
hang out with us I go a lot man but I'm
always I'm in and out and I'm always in
the city yeah I'm always at the
Intercontinental oh yeah right by the
green door I'm just what's the Green
Door blue oh yeah it's across the street
yeah from the hotel yeah come to Oakland
man yeah I asked that because in in
Vegas there's a [ __ ] sex club called
The Green Door oh no no no I used to
live in Vegas so like there used to be
this place called The Green Door that
was in the parking lot of a night club
we did and I would be like what the [ __ ]
is a swinger club because in the middle
of Vegas also Harris there's pure trees
over here yeah but she'll come to
Oakland man I got to man that's the
culture I got to every time I'm in town
I'm like well you know what I haven't
been I haven't been in a few months but
next time I'm back I gotta I'm always in
and out though like East West North when
I come to San Francisco I have like a
checklist of things
so I just run around doing those things
and then when I have a second to breathe
out try to get some good food and then
if you ever want to see like the real
culture of the bay area and we could
have all these debates that we want to
Bear you got to come over I need to
Oakland is the I mean I've been to
Oakland Oakland no I haven't like tapped
in with Oakland for sure I need to there
it is the boy Dame I'm gonna follow my
guy go stream the new records
bootlegate podcast